2014 pour moi a été une année de
jardinage fantastique en 2014
j'ai tué mon gazon écoutez ça me repris
10 en dix ans de guerre biologique et
psychologique
pourquoi psychologique parce qu'on aime
la gazon pensez-y une belle étendue
verte uniforme avec le soleil dessus il
ya des gens qui sont à 6 heures pause et
des gens qui pique nique et des gens qui
se promènent ya des gens qui jouent on
aime le gazon même les enfants lorsqu'il
dessine une maison qu'est ce qui met
autour du gardon fait que saddam a donc
pris beaucoup de temps avant de tuer mon
gazon mais quand j'ai acheté ma maison
en 2002 j'avais certainement l'intention
d'avoir un gazon un beau gazon
quand je suis arrivé c'était l'automne
le gazon était complètement gris mais je
me suis dit c'est l'automne c'est normal
je te comme pas trop inquiète et j'ai
commencé à préparer ma saison de
jardinage 2003 j'ai donc fait
l'acquisition des éléments essentiels au
jardinage des gants des bottes une pelle
un arrosoir intailles bordures et le
joyeux ma collection
une tondeuse à rouleaux avec un système
de roulements à bille extraordinaire
pensez-y
c'était en tout cas
2003 et arrivée le printemps est arrivé
le gaz a poussé la gazon était gris non
comme tout autodidacte
j'étais pas découragé je me suis dit je
veux faire une recherche sur internet
j'ai trouvé comment entretenir mon gazon
capot fait une recherche sur internet
qu'on marque entretien du gazon on tombe
sur 127 millions de sites
si vous faites entre thiais du jardin
vous tombez sur soixante dix millions de
sites
c'est juste pour vous dire à quel point
on aime le gaz
parmi les cent soixante dix millions de
sites j'en ai choisi est celui du jardin
botanique de montréal
ce sont des experts il ya un certain
nombre d'étapes à respecter pour faire
pousser un beau gazon
première étape la tonte ne jamais couper
plus du tiers de la longueur de votre
gazon pour arriver à une longueur finale
de 7 points 5 cm ça veut dire qu'il faut
mesurer votre gazon pour le commensal
coupé lorsqu'il est à 11 cm les remue
mur de gazon ne pas ramasser les
rognures de gazon
si vous n'avez pas de tondeuses
déchiqueteuse repasser sur les murs pour
accélérer la décomposition
ça veut dire qu'il faut tondre le gazon
deux fois
l'arrosage le gazon a besoin de 2.5 cm
d'eau par semaine afin de savoir si
votre gazon a plus ou moins besoin d'eau
déposé sur votre terrain des contenants
lorsque vous atteindrez 2.5 cm d'eau cc
l'arrosage alors si vous avez des
enfants
les comptes ne reste pas sur le gazon
très très longtemps
il restait beaucoup d'autres étapes mais
rendu là je n'avais plus le temps la
saison 2003 s'est terminé la saison 2004
commencer le gazon a fait semblant de
pousser et là je me suis mis à le
détester
je me suis rendu compte que je mettais
beaucoup d'énergie de temps à faire
pousser quelque chose qui ne sert à rien
pourquoi on fait des efforts dans notre
vie pourquoi on se lève on va travailler
pourquoi on a de la patience si on met
de l'énergie pour notre bien-être
physique et psychologique bien figurez
vous qu'elle gazon ça nourrit personne
est en train de me rend folle 80 % des
gens en amérique du nord ont une pelouse
le bureau de la statistique américaine a
déterminé que chez les gens de plus de
15 ans on passe en moyenne 72 heures par
année à tondre son gazon ou entretenir
son jardin
je fais un petit calcul je me suis dit
on aux états unis et en programmant six
mois de gazon par année si je transpose
ce au canada donc on est un petit peu
moins d'un jeu mais ce sur dix semaines
d'été donc on doit faire à peu près 3
points 5 heures par semaines
d'entretiens de notre gazon et de notre
jardin
si vous avez deux études dans votre
maison imaginez combien ce secteur
imaginez si vous prenez ce temps là pour
faire pousser un potager parfois ce à
quoi on est habitués ne nous convient
pas nous avons toutes sortes d'habitude
dans notre quotidien des habitudes qui
sont issus de conventions sociales de
conventions familial mais vous êtes vous
posé la question est ce que ces
habitudes leur convienne vraiment
et moi quand je me suis rendu compte que
mon gazon ne me convenait pas j'ai
arrêté de le détester
en fait je les tuer
ça m'a pris dix pendant dix ans mes
voisins se sont habitués à mon jardin
qui était en transformation perpétuelle
maintenant dans mon jardin je peux
pousser 20 plants de tomates dit plan du
qu'il est vite plantes concombres je
vais pousser des carottes des radis des
oignons et cette année nous avons eu
trois citrouilles
c'est quand même fantastique est ce que
mes voisins sont habitués à mon jardin
depuis dix ans je pense que oui sont
quand même un peu indulgents est-ce que
je prends moins de temps qu'avant dans
mon jardin non est ce que je regrette
quelque chose
ma tondeuse mais quoi qu'il en soit une
chose de certaine l'été prochain chez
nous on mangera pas de gazon merci